Okay, so
we'll finish up Markov chains today, and
welcome to our Pen
ultimate Stat 110 lecture.
So remind me what we were doing well last
time, we were talking about reversible.
Well a lot of things got Markov chains,
but most importantly last time,
we're talking about
reversible Markov chains.
We did the example, a random walk
on an undirected network, right?
And there's another important example
of reversible MArkov chains is
birth-death chains, which I think
you can read about on the handout.
It's worth working it through, but
I wanted to talk about one kind of
generalization while we're still
talking about reversible Markov chains.
So just to remind you from last time, and
then we'll try to extend it a little bit.
We were looking at random undirected
graph or undirected network.
It looks something like,
I'm just gonna draw a picture.
You have a bunch of nodes and
some of them have edges between them and
they're not one way arrows, right?
They're bidirectional, so you can go,
let say from 1 to 2 and 2 to 4 and
1 to 4 and 3 to 4 and
maybe there's a 5 here that can goes to 3.
And so whatever we wanna draw,
we have a picture that looks like this.
And if we want, we can add loops which
we didn't worry about last time.
But it's no big deal, we could have
an edge connecting it, a node to itself.
The only thing we have to be careful about
there is there are different conventions
for what does this
contribute to the degree.
So remember the degree of each node
is just the number of edges and
some people like to count the degree
in different ways for this.
Well let's just assume this counts as 1.
So in this picture node 1 has degree 3,
cuz there's this edge to itself,
and then two edges that are going out.
We got a picture that looks like this,
and we proved last time that
the stationary probability of any node
is proportional to its degree, right?
And that is, we don't have to do
any matrix calculations at all.
If we want the stationary
distribution of the Markov chain,
which is just randomly wandering
around on this network.
All we have to do is list out
the vector of all the degrees.
This has degree 3, this has degree 2, and
just count the number of edges, right?
And then normalize that vector,
so that multiply by a constant so
that it adds up to 1, and
then that's the stationary distribution.
We proved that last time
using reversibility.
So now I wanted to extend
that a little bit and say,
well what would actually happen if we,
so we were assuming last time that,
let's say you're here at state 4 and
you see three choices.
We assume they're all equally likely,
right?
So one-third, one-third, one-third.
So a natural question is
what happens if certain
edges are more likely for
some reason, right?
That they're unequal weights, so
to handle that all we need to
do is put down some weights.
So let's call this w12, I'm just gonna
put little weights on the edges.
This is w11,
w14 I'm not gonna fill them all in.
In general, let's say we have wij,
Greater than or
equal to 0, we call that an edge weight.
And let's assume that wij = 0,
if there's no edge there, right?
That just means you can't get
from i to j in one step, so
we just give that weight 0.
And then the other ones,
which is just let's say it's greater or
equal to well.
We can assume it's strictly greater that
if they are actually is an edge, but
it doesn't actually matter,
as long as we avoid dividing by 0.
And then our key assumption is that
wij = wji, that's an assumption.
Another way to say that is because we're
talking about random undirected network.
And I only wrote one number here, w12.
Maybe w12 is 3, it's just some number.
But I'm not allowed to write one number
that applies going this direction,
and another number that applies this
direction, so the same number, okay?
So we may as well just express that
as a symmetry condition, wij = eji.
And now the way the random walk proceeds
is that, so here's our random walk,
analogous to what we did before, except
we're generalizing with these weights.
All we do is we say, okay,
suppose that we are at state 4, and
then I see there's 3 different possible
edges, and each one has its weight.
And we look at these three choices and
then we just choose proportional
to the weights, right?
So if we let all the weights be 1, then
we do one-third, one-third, one-third,
but maybe w24 is relatively larger, right?
It's just proportional.
So from state i,
Go to j with probability
proportional to wij.
Looks like an alpha, that's
proportionality symbol to wij, okay?
So if wij is 0,
then obviously it says we don't go there.
So we look at all
the available choices and
choose what probability's
proportional to the weights we see.
So that's the generalization
of the problem, and
let's solve in an analogous way.
This is still gonna be reversible, so
we wanna write down reversibility
equation siqij = sjqji.
Okay, let's first write down what's qij?
So if ij is actually an edge,
if it's not an edge the probability
is 0 going from i to j.
If it is an edge,
that is there is an edge there,
Then by definition qij,
the transition probability
from state i to state j by
definition is just the weight
divided by the sum of
the possible weights.
That is the sum of the weights
of the possible steps, right?
Code proportional, so this'll be the
denominator will just be the sum of wik,
over all k, All right?
And we're assuming that the denominator is
non-zero, because we have to be able to
do something, so
we don't all weight 0, all right?
So that's the random walk,
but notice that then
it's true that if we, so
in the case without weights,
just think of all these wijs as one,
right?
And so then this is just one over
the degree of i in that case.
And in that case, the stationary
distribution proportional to degrees.
So the analogue of that is that instead
of the degree we're looking at the sum of
the weights.
That is from state i, we look at all
these weights and we add them up, right?
So okay, if we do that notice that,
If we take the sum of,
I'm just gonna multiply by
this denominator here, right?
So I'll take this thing,
sum of overall k, Of w i j,
that's the generalization of
degree to the weighted case.
And if we multiply by q i j,
Then that just cancels the denominator,
which is why I chose that, [LAUGH] okay?
That's w i j, but
by assumption, w i j = w j i,
so that would be the same thing as if
we did it the other way around, and
did the sum over all k of w,
this should be w i k.
So it's summing over all,
k is a dummy variable.
Sum over all k, w i k.
And here we (sum over all k, w j k)q j i
That's the reversibility equation.
So therefore, the stationary distribution,
S i,
the stationary probability of state i,
is proportional to this
generalized degree, w i k over k.
This is proportionality, but
if we wanna know what it's equal to,
we would just divide by
the sum of this over all i.
So this is completely analogous to what
we did last time, but it's good practice.
And all we did was just multiply
both sides by this denominator,
and used the symmetry, w i j = w j i.
Then we get the stationary distribution
without needing to do any matrices.
So I don't know if this seems
like a small generalization or
a large generalization of
what we did last time.
It's a generalization of
Actually, this is completely general,
reversible Markov chain.
So this is actually a complete
generalization, in the sense that if we
have any reversible Markov chain,
we can actually interpret it this way.
So In a sense, this is the entire
theory of reversible Markov chains.
Not exactly, because,
if you have a reversible Markov chain,
and you know what the S i is,
then you're in good shape.
But if you don't know that,
it may not be obvious to figure
out what are the stationary.
What is the S i, such that S i,
q i j equals S j, q j i, okay?
But it's a theorem that any
reversible Markov chain can be
represented in this form.
So just to quickly see why that's true.
So any reversible chain can
be thought of this way.
It may not be obvious to figure out
how to come up with the w i j's and
stuff like that.
But at least in principle,
it can be written this way,
any reversible chain is of this form.
So why is that true?
Well, we just need to define the w i j's.
It's pretty obvious what network we should
use, just the nodes are the states,
and we put edges whenever
q i j is positive, right?
And all we need to do is just say,
what are the weights?
So to do that, let's just say okay,
let w i j = S i, q i j.
That's the thing that we wanted, right?
But S i j, q i j, right now I'm
assuming it's reversible, and
I wanna show that the Markov
chain can be viewed in this way.
So I'm assuming we already have the S and
the q, and I wanna define the weights,
such that the Markov chain just
is this particular random walk..
So if we define the weight i j to be S i,
q i j, but since it's reversible,
that's the same thing as S j,
q j i, so that would be our w j i.
So we will have this condition hold.
And all we have to do to check
that this works is to show that,
if we define the weights this way, and
just do this particular random walk.
Let's show that it has the transition
probablies that we want,
which are the q i j.
So in other words,
we're assuming we have q i j,
that's our Markov chain
that we're interested in.
And we're assuming that it's reversible,
so this holds.
And we're showing that it can
be written in this way, right?
Well, do do that, at this point, all
we have to do is check that this chain,
which is random walk on this network,
with the weights defined this way,
has the transition probabilities
that we want, right?
Which are q i j by definition, okay?
So what are the transition
probabilities here?
Well, I'll just write it as,
what's the probability of X n+1,
if this X process is random
walk on this network.
X n+1 = j given X n = i, that's
the transition probability that we have.
Well, by definition, how do we find
the transition probability from i to j?
Well, that says okay, we're at state i,
we look around everywhere,
where are the available edges?
We look at all their weights, and
we choose to go to j with
probability proportional to w i j.
That's the definition of the random walk.
So the probability is w i j over
the sum of w i k over all of k.
That's just the definition of how
we did the random walk, right?
Now if we plug in what's w i j,
w i j is S i, q i j, and
we divide by the sum of S i, q i k.
I'm just plugging in how we defined,
we defined the weights in this way,
I'm plugging in the definition.
Now let's just simplify this So
this S i in
the denominator does not depend on k,
so we can take that out of the sum.
I'm assuming that the S i's are positive.
It's not a very interesting chain if
some stationery probabilities zero,
then we should have just restricted
the space, and not included them anyway.
So I'm assuming we're not
dividing by zero here.
S i's cancel, so this is just q
i j divided by the sum q i k.
All right, well, what's the sum of q i k?
It's 1, that should be quick, as it says.
Why is that 1?
Because it's a Markov chain, so
you have to go from i to somewhere,
so that's 1, so that's just q i j.
So in other words,
this chain that we constructed has
the desired transition probabilities.
Okay, so
this is the quintessential prototypical
example of a reversible Markov chain.
It's a random walk on and
undirected network,
where possibly we put some
weights on the edges.
So that's the reversible case.
And I wanted to do one example
of a non-reversible chain.
That non-reversible, in general,
is gonna be much more difficult, right?
In the reversible case, it just really
has a lot of really nice properties,
both intuitively, cuz you think about
time running backwards and forwards.
And practically, you can avoid matrix
stuff a lot of times, things like that.
Non-reversible We can still think of it
as random walk on a network with weights,
except that we have arrows,
maybe one way arrows or two way arrows.
And you can have different
weights in both directions.
That extra generality makes it much,
much, much harder, okay?
So just wanna do one example
of a non-reversible chain.
Non-reversible example.
Okay, and then that example is Google,
Google Chain, more precisely,
Google PageRank.
Google PageRank, which was the algorithm
that Google originally used,
and still is using some form of,
is based exactly on a Markov chain,
and it happens to be
a non-reversible chain.
And I want to tell you
about what that chain is,
how it's useful, where that came from.
Okay, so this is just one example, but
this is a very big, important example.
Has anyone here heard of Google?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, well if not, Google for it, and
you'll find a lot of stuff there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a search engine.
And, it's all based on MAakov chains.
So I basically wanna
explain how that works.
So, well,
you can kind of guess that what the chain,
the states are gonna be, webpages, right?
And the links are gonna be links,
right, hyperlinks.
That is, we have the entire World Wide
Web, and some pages link to other pages,
and that's gonna form a Markov chain.
We're gonna look at the stationary
distribution of that chain and
see what we can say.
It's not gonna be reversible, so
we can't just write down the stationary
distribution as easily as there.
But we can still talk about how
could you try to compute that thing.
Especially, considering
how large the web is.
Okay, so just for
the sake of having a picture,
let's assume that the World Wide Web
only has four pages.
Which is an underestimate, but at least
I can draw something conceptually.
So, there's only four pages on the web.
I just made up a little example.
So, we have four webpages,
numbered one through four, and
as I said, we're gonna draw
arrows that just represent links.
So, it's just this example that I made up.
Page number 1 links to page number 3,
that is, if you go to this web page,
you see a link that takes
you to this web page.
Okay, page 1 links to page 2,
page 2 links back to page 1.
Page 3 is not so nice,
they don't link back to page 1.
Page 2 links to page 3 and
page 3 only links to page 4.
Page 4 has no links on it.
Not every web page links to other pages.
It may just be that page, all right?
So that's an oversimplification
of the web, but
this gives you something to think.
If you understand conceptually really
well what's going on with four pages,
then you could imagine, in principle,
there could be billions of pages and
you're just imaging a gigantic version.
It's not a very complicated
link structure, but
basically you just have web pages
linking to each other ,okay, so
I wanna basically explain
what this algorithm does.
Just to put it in context.
I'll talk a little bit about
the earlier history of search engines.
Google was started in 1998 by Brin and
Page, who were Stanford grad students.
They ended up dropping out
to work full time on Google.
The name is kind of convenient,
Brin and Page.
Larry Page is kind of convenient for
him that Page is in the name PageRank,
but it's also a pretty natural name.
Right?
Because this is a way for
ranking web pages.
The basic problem is,
suppose you search for
a certain thing you're interested in,
okay, and there might be millions or
even billions of pages on the web
that contain that topic, right?
So the fundamental question and
the insight that made Google way,
way better than any of the other
alternatives at that time.
I mean, now you can debate whether
their still the best or not, but
at the time it was a huge,
way beyond any of their competitors
in terms of the ranking, right?
Because you don't have time to search
through a million, you're searching for
chess and there's a million pages, you
don't have time to go through all of them.
The question is,
which page should come up first, second,
third, it's the ranking, right?
All pages that match your query,
what order should those be displayed in?
Okay?
So the earlier websites took pretty
crude naive approaches to that question.
For example, I mean some of the earlier
search engines were basically trying
to be human curated, like a museum.
You have someone who recommends
this page is really good, right?
And obviously that doesn't scale so
well when the web has billions and
billions of pages now.
It didn't scale so well.
And then, I don't know, so
maybe what else could they have done,
like alphabetical or something like,
it's kind of useless.
In some of the early search engines,
the ordering was based on how many
times the page used that word, right.
So if I'm looking for chess,
then a page that mentions chess 100 times
must be much better than a page
that only mentions chess once.
Okay, well obviously that
opens itself up to abuse.
Right?
You can just list the dictionary on your
site like repeated many times.
But one thing, even if you're not
trying to abuse the system, just
using the same word over and over again
doesn't mean that is the most reliable,
insightful, useful page on that topic.
Okay, so
the earliest sites were not really using
the network structure of the web at all.
Possibly AltaVista was one of
the first search engines that
actually at least tried to do something
with the actual structure of the web.
And so at some point it was
realized that actually,
right, this is the worldwide
web is a network, and
the structure of that network is valuable
information for doing these rankings.
Okay, so then they started basically
saying that a page is important if
a lot of other pages link to it, right?
Which was a big improvement.
The problems with that, well first of
all it's very easy to abuse that, right?
Can easily just create thousands of
dummy pages linking to your page, but
even aside from the abuse question,
it's like just because a certain page
has a lot of other pages linking to it
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
that important if those pages that
link to it are garbage, right?
So the insight of PageRank
was that the importance
of a page should be based not just on
how many other pages link to it, but
how important those pages are, right?
So that's the key idea.
So we have to try to make
that mathematical and
then show how that
relates to Markov chains.
But just intuitively, the importance of
a page as we want to rank the We wanna
give each page a score for
how important it is, right?
And rank them in order of
importance in this sense.
Importance of page should be based,
not only on which page is linking to it,
the number of pages, and
the importance of each one
Well, that sounds like a circular
definition that we define
importance in terms of importance,
but that's okay actually,
because that just suggests
an Eigenvector value equation,
which will interpret it as a Markov chain.
So if we let Si,
just think of S as standing for score.
That is,
we're gonna give each web page a score.
And let me just index it with j.
So that's the score of the jth web page.
And so, Brin and Paige Said, they defined,
they said we wanna give each page a score,
such that SSJ equals the sum of Si, qij.
And I'll tell you qij is,
summed over all i.
qij, well,
they pointed out basically, I mean,
a simple thing to do would just be
to let this score of the jth page be
the sum of all the scores of all,
summed over all i that link to j, right?
So in other words, if you're thinking
of a link, an incoming link,
as recommending that page and add up all
the scores of the recommenders, right?
Except the problem with that is that,
some pages may only have like one
outgoing link and other pages may
have a thousand outgoing links and
it seems a little unfair to count those
kind of as equal recommendations, right?
So it's like imagine that a certain
page has a certain budget for
how much stuff it can recommend, and so
if it recommends 1,000 pages by having
1,000 links, then each of those
should be diluted, right?
So that's what this qij is gonna do.
So we're gonna let our matrix Q
just be the matrix we would get
if we think of this as a Markov
chain just for this example.
And we think of a Markov chain where
we're just randomly following links.
So in this example I made up,
from page one you can go to page two or
page three, assume equal probabilities.
So it would do 0 1/2 1/2 0 it
goes to page two or page three.
From page two you can go to page one or
page three.
So from page 2 you can go to 1 or
3 so 1/2 0, 1/2 0.
From page 3 you can only go to page 4.
So that's just gonna be 0, 0, 0, 1.
Page 4 is kind of annoying, right?
They don't recommend anything,
they're just their own thing.
But we actually want to
have a Markov chain here.
So we assume that from page 4,
you can go anywhere on the web with
equal probability, so
I'm gonna just change this to 1/4,
1/4, that's if it links to everything.
Okay, so you define Q in this way,
where doing all the links,
but you're making each row sum up to 1.
And if there's a page that has no
links then just make it 1 over
the number of pages in the entire web.
So this has a pretty natural
interpretation that you might call,
that is what you imagine is you have, and
this is kind of what they were thinking
about that part of the motivation I think
that helped them as you imagine someone
randomly surfing the web, right?
So what do you do?
Well, you're Read a page for a while and
then you're done with that page.
And if you're really bored,
just start clicking random links, right?
Click a random link, it's a lot
of fun to do on Wikipedia, right?
There was a good XKCD about that, right?
Click a random link,
you keep clicking random links, right?
Just randomly surfing the web.
That's kind of a natural
thing to think about.
And then, now what happens if you
reach a page that has no links,
but you're not ready to
stop surfing the web yet?
You don't give up in despair.
Then the assumption is then
you just open a new window and
just go to another random page, right?
So then you can random walk instead of
being, you don't really wanna be trapped
on that page forever just because
it doesn't have any links right?
So that's what this chain is doing.
Okay, so then this equation
should make some sense, right?
The importance is based on the importance
of the pages that link to it.
qij is zero, unless there's
actually a link from i to j.
So you're only adding up the terms
where there actually is a link there.
And then the qij's may not all be equal,
because of this dilution thing, all right?
So in matrix notation now,
that just says that s,
which is s is the vector of
all the page ranks, right?
It is equal to s times Q.
Ie, what does that say?
That equation looks familiar, right?
It says that s is
the stationary distribution.
S is the stationary distribution for
this random web-surfing chain.
Random web surfing,
random web surfing chain.
Okay, so this has a natural interpretation
in terms of stationary distributions
as well that is intuitively we think
of the stationary distribution as
giving the long-run probabilities of
being in different states, right?
Which says,
I'll just clarify that if s is normalized.
Of course, if you have any solution to
this just divide by a constant to make,
as long as you have non-negative
numbers here, so if s is normalized.
So we just solve this matrix equation,
right?
This is some gigantic
linear system of equations
that is billions of pages, right?
So if there are 10 billion web pages
then Q is gonna be a 10 billion by 10
billion matrix, so this is an immensely
difficult computational problem.
But in principle, all you're doing
is solving this linear system, and
normalizing it, and
then that's the stationary distribution,
by definition of stationary distribution.
So in terms of the interpretation of
stationary distribution is the long run
fraction of time being in a certain state.
What this is saying is that, if you
imagine just randomly surfing the web for
ages and ages and ages, and in the long
run this says that the importance
of a page is the long run fraction of
time that you spend at that page, right.
So that's kind of intuitive, right.
The pages that are more important,
you'll find yourself spending
more time there in the long run.
So that's what it's doing.
Okay, so you can interpret this is
a Markov chain, as I just said.
But you might object.
Well really this is just an eigenvalue,
eigenvector thing.
It's just a matrix equation, and
do we really have to give it this
probability interpretation and
really interpret it as a Markov chain?
And so I wanted to show you something
about why is that actually a useful way to
think of it.
One reason is what I just said.
That intuitively it makes sense to think
of these long run fraction of time for
randomly surfing the web.
So this gives a nice extra
interpretation to this.
But I also wanna show you how
this helps with the computation.
Because the computation
is immensely difficult.
If you try to solve,
you know the usual method for
solving matrix equations is
Gaussian elimination, right?
You do all these row operations.
Two times row one, plus row three,
and swap rows, and multiply rows.
Right?
All that thing.
The complexity of Gaussian elimination
if you have m linear equations and
m variables is of the order of m cubed.
It's a cubic complexity.
You may be happy that that's polynomial
time but in practice it's not so
good if m is like 10 billion and
if you have the order
of 10 billion that's 10 to the 10,
cube it, that's 10 to the 30.
10 to the 30.
So you'd have order 10 to
the 30th operations to perform.
You don't wanna do that,
even on a fast computer.
Okay, so I wanna show you how
Markov chains not only gives you
a nice interpretation here,
it actually helps with the computation.
Which is as far as I know, at least how
Google was originally doing this and
I'm sure they've refined things,
but in spirit it should be similar.
That the basic principle.
So to give this the full Markov
chain interpretation, we wanna,
and connect this back with what we were
doing, we wanna say is this irreducible?
Does this have a stationary, how do we
know the stationary distribution exists?
And how do we know to convert it to
the stationary and things like that.
So actually, what Google uses or
used in the original, Brin and Page,
while they were still grad students,
wrote a paper with the idea for Google.
And then they started
actually the company.
So the paper that they wrote
actually gives the ideas.
And what they said in that paper is,
they set up an equation like this,
but then they said actually we're
going to use another chain instead,
which I'll call G for Google.
But here's the actual Google chain.
The Google chain is alpha times
this one that we just did.
It's mixing together two Markov chains.
Alpha times Q, so Q is the matrix
we just defined based on the web,
+ (1- alpha) times J over M,
where M is the number of pages.
So in other words Q is an m by m matrix,
and J is the matrix of all ones.
So I want to explain why did they do this.
And alpha is a number between 0 and 1.
Just a constant.
So think of alpha as a probability,
because it's a number between 0 and 1.
So what this is saying is imagine
that you have this person randomly
surfing the web like we were saying.
And with probability alpha,
so they flip a coin that has
probability alpha of heads each time.
If the coin lands heads,
they just click a random link on
the page that they were on, right?
That is they actually use the Q chain.
But if the coin lands tails,
they use this chain instead.
Notice J over M is a valid
Markov transition matrix, right,
cuz the row sums are 1,
and it's all non-negative.
So with probability alpha,
just follow the link.
With probably 1- alpha,
we do what's called teleportation.
Teleportation is just a fancy word for
saying, don't follow
the link structure anymore.
Now, just go to a random,
uniformly random page.
So this term is the teleportation.
All that means is, with probability alpha,
just follow the link structure.
With probably 1- alpha, just open up
a new window in your web browser and
go to a completely random
page at that point.
Of course, alpha has to be chosen.
The original paper suggested alpha = 0.85.
Now, that's like Google's magic number,
0.85.
And there's been a lot of speculation and
discussion on why did they use .85?
And I don't know whether
they still use 0.85.
That was the original
value that they proposed.
So 85% of the time you're
just following random links,
15% of the time you're
teleporting to random pages.
The reason, not specifically for
this 0.85, but the reason for adding
this extra term is that this makes things
really, well, one reason is it makes
things really nice in terms of the theory
that we developed for stationary issues.
But the actual web, you know,
if we just had this part, we don't know
whether it's irreducible, you know.
Can you get from anywhere on the web
to anywhere just by clicking links?
Well, I guess if you have this
page it would help a lot but
it may take ages to get
from one page to another.
And this is kind of allowing there to
be some small probability of getting
from anywhere to anywhere in one step.
So this guarantees irreducibility for
one thing.
And we have other result about,
the nice case is when some
power of the transition
matrix has all entries positive.
In this case, notice this is
extremely tiny, tiny, right?
If alpha is 0.85, this is 0.15.
M may be 10 billion.
So you're adding some tiny number,
but at least everything's positive.
You don't have zeroes anymore.
So, no zeroes in transition matrix G.
So, that has some advantages.
And in particular we know
that all the results about...
Even though it's not a reversible chain,
because the arrows may be going
in one direction for
the web, the results from
last time that I stated, that there
exists geostationary distribution.
It's unique.
The chain will converge to it.
All this nice stuff applies.
Okay, so we have this thing.
Now, how do we actually compute?
Because, since it's non-reversible,
we can't just write down a simple
equation and immediately write
down the stationary distribution.
The stationary distribution,
is something very very complicated here.
But on the other hand,
if we go back to the definition and
try to solve this matrix equation, then
we're trying to do Gaussian elimination
with ten billion or 100 billion equations.
It's not so good, right?
So, the idea for computation is to
use the fact that the chain converges
to the stationary distribution.
So use convergence to
stationary distribution
to stationarity to actually to solve.
We don't need to solve it exactly, right?
All we really need is and
approximate solution to this.
Okay, so we know that if we run this,
this defines a Markov chain, right?
Either you follow the link structure,
or you teleport each time.
Follow that, run that chain for
a long time.
It's gonna converge to the stationary
distribution no matter what
the starting point was, right?
Start with any distribution you want.
Run the chain for a long.
There's some very
difficult mathematical and
computational questions about how
long should you run the chain for.
And those are not really well understood
for a chain as complicated as this.
So in practice, what people will do
is just run it as long as they can or
run it until it looks
like it has stabilized.
And you don't know for
sure that if you then ran it another week,
it would change to something else.
But if it looks like it's stabilized,
then just take that as
your approximate solution.
Okay, so
how do we actually run this chain though?
The computation it looks like
it's going to be extremely,
extremely difficult because of
these matrices are so large.
It's actually much simpler than it
looks and I just want to show you why.
So let's be t be our
initial probability vector.
That is if you want t could just be 1 and
then all 0s.
That just says always start out at page 1,
right,
or let t be 1 over m, 1 over m all the way
through that it starts on a random page.
We need some starting distribution
to start out the chain.
So that's the initial,
in other words, this is the PMF,
at times 0, written as a row vector.
So initial probability vector.
Okay, so we proved before that if we
want the probability distribution
after one step, all we have to do
is multiply on the right by G.
Right?
So
t times G is going to be
the distribution after one step.
Right?
We did that before.
And then if we want the distribution after
two steps, we multiply this by G, so
we can get tG squared,
tG cubed, and so on, all right?
Okay.
So,
let's just quickly see what is
t times G actually look like?
So t times G,
I'm just gonna multiply this by t,
this is alpha t q plus 1
minus alpha t J over M.
And actually this is not so
complicated because
when you think about what Q looks like, Q,
that's this chain that captures the link
structure of the entire web, right?
What do you think that matrix looks like,
intuitively?
>> A lot of 0s.
>> It's a lot of zeroes,
this is like 10 billion by 10 billion, or
100 billion by 100 billion But, right,
a typical page might have, I don't know,
three links or ten links or
even 100 links.
You're not gonna have many pages that
have tens of thousands of links, or
millions of links, right?
But this is a 10 billion by 10 billion,
okay?
So this is dominated by 0s.
So in other words,
you would say it's very sparse.
That is sparse, meaning mostly zeros.
Now, Google has a lot of very, very,
very good computer scientists working on
some of the data storage computational
issues of the, what data structure would
you use to store this matrix and keep
track of where all the zeros are, right?
In other words, how do you efficiently
keep track of where the zeros are and
where the non-zero terms
are because it's mostly zeros?
But at least intuitively this
matrix has so many zeros in it and
having a lot of zeros makes it a lot
easier to do matrix multiplication, right?
You do need to be clever in keeping
track of where the zeros are.
But it helps a lot with
doing this multiplication.
Now let's look at this other term.
Let's think about t times J.
So remember t, t is just some vector
of probabilities that add up to 1.
Right?
And then J is a very simple matrix.
J is just all 1's.
So I'm gonna take this vector t,
and I'm gonna multiply it by J.
And then I just,
the matrix multiplication,
tt is a real vectors are going row,
dot it with a column.
But you do a dot product with all ones,
that just says add up the entries of t.
Well if you add up the entries of t,
you get 1, right?
Because t is a probability vector.
So t times J is just all 1s.
Cuz you're just going t,
add up the elements of t.
t elements add up to what?
That's very easy, just all ones.
So that term is easy, so
actually this is not as bad as it looks.
Now that we have t times G,
we use that as the new t.
This is after running it for one step.
Then we do tG squared, that is we
do tg times G, which is tG squared.
Well we do that in the same way, which is
tG is now playing the role of t and we
multiply this by G and that's not typical
to do for the same reasons I just said.
So then we have tG squared,
tG cubed, and so
on, run this for a very long time,
that is tG to some large
power that corresponds to running this
chain for a large number of steps, right?
So then, in the limit, if you do tG to
the n, meaning you ran it for n steps,
and you let n go to infinity, that's gonna
converge to the stationary distribution.
The stationary distribution
is the page rank vector.
So then you have page rank, okay?
So, and that's actually computationally, a
lot easier to do, just run this chain, in
this way rather than trying to solve the
ten billion by ten billion matrix system.
And it has this nice interpretation in
terms of randomly clicking links and
randomly teleporting every now and then.
All right, so
that's the essence of Google PageRank.
And that's the end of Markov chains.
So I'll see you on Friday.